renee what's going on uh today i'm
calling uh i
need help in navigating the relationship
between myself and my
uh 17 year old daughter okay so i'll
give you a little bit of background um
so i met my wife
back in 2010 and
she was seven-year-old at the time from
a previous relationship my
wife had when where the dad was never
really involved
okay and they were both living with my
mother-in-law and pretty much that's all
my
daughter knew so they were pretty close
my wife and i dated and got married the
following year
and i adopted her you know it wasn't a
question of if i was or i wasn't hey
renee can i stop you right there
sure you're a stud dude thank you
i just want to stop and acknowledge that
i'm
grateful for you that men like you are
out there
and willing to not only fall in love and
get married but it's going to take that
next step
and make this this
seven-year-old this eight-year-old a
part of a full family
kudos to you brother that's awesome all
right continue
all right so i'm in the military and uh
shortly after we got married in 2011
uh we received orders to uh move
overseas
uh and pretty much uh this
when we did this we left my
mother-in-law in california
okay uh during our first year there uh
we had a baby
and during this time um my mother-in-law
uh who had depression for for a while
passed away uh due to lung cancer
and my daughter and my mother-in-law
were extremely close they were best
friends
so it really took a toll on her yeah um
during this time obviously you know
moving
adjusting to a new sibling she also had
kind of
feelings that she didn't fit in at
school sure
the reason i say this is because she's a
mixed kid
my wife's white i'm mexican and uh my
daughter is half black
okay so i mean i'm pretty sure you've
dealt with stuff like this you know
she's not gonna be accepted by the white
kids and sometimes uh you know
she was struggling because she wasn't
black enough to be with the black kids
from what my daughter would tell me you
know absolutely and is she was she in a
dodd school overseas
correct okay so we saw
a family therapist for about two and a
half years with
not a lot of change um
you know everyone she saw she didn't
really like she didn't really try to
open
up to them you know and i figured that
was the case because you know all this
stuff
will put a lot of pressure on her but
essentially from what me and my wife got
it was she kind of got the
the role of me against the world yep
from what we feel and she didn't really
get over it
um so kind of uh so we've moved back to
or uh we got stationed in el paso about
four years ago okay and our relationship
has had its ups and downs you know from
really highs really lows
um my wife and i have been trying to
show her we love her but sometimes it
seems like it's never enough
yeah um so it's kind of like hey uh
if it's something uh that
we agree with her or that's fun with her
she loves it you know we're
we're the best parents in the world but
if we don't agree with her or if there's
other stuff
you know taking time uh away from uh
you know not the spotlight on her but
just spending time with her
she says that you know she's not loved
and she's alone okay
and for the past couple of years we've
been trying to
prepare her since she got into high
school like hey prepare for adulthood
and you know
it's it's been tough to say the least
right um
she is a great kid she gets good grades
uh
she's very very considerate and loves
her siblings so
now we just got baby number number four
whoa
um yes uh so baby number four
in addition to her so you've got five no
so she's the number or uh the new baby's
baby number four
okay excellent okay so uh she's just
never been a kid that
takes a lot of initiative and stuff like
that even if it's for her benefit
sure sometimes it's like pulling teeth
but i'm assuming that's uh
likely with all teenagers uh she has
this dream of attending a
four-year state college become a
psychologist stuff like that
but where you know we just started
following dave ramsey a couple of years
ago
my wife turned me on to it and and you
know we're getting there but
that for her that means that we're not
going to be able to financially help her
a whole lot sure so with some of this
stuff
uh each thing that we've been trying to
do just it's kind of met with the
resistance sure and right now our
relationship
it's probably the worst it's ever been
you know
she's kind of gaining a voice 17 you
know she knows
she wants to move out of the house when
she's 18 and and go to college
it's just one of those things that you
know just because we love her i
i don't want to lie to her or send her
on the wrong path
right so we don't see eye to eye very
much on
a lot of her decisions
and right now i'm pretty uh physically
and mentally drained i don't want to
fight with her but i also don't want to
stop being her parent
and do things that benefit her you know
absolutely i want to focus instead of
uh building our relationship obviously
yeah you know
it's just one of those things that right
now i just feel like i can't reason with
emotions sometimes
and some of you she has especially with
the
cancel type of uh you know mentality
so i think right now for the past month
it's
you know she's been ignoring me stuff
like that and i don't know what to do
um man there's a lot there so again i
don't that's the second time i'm going
to do this in the same call
um i want to commend you for being a dad
who loves his daughter and is trying to
figure it out
and again you're you're the noblest of
the nobleman man i thank you for your
military service i thank you for
really plugging in and trying to get at
the heart of what's
going on at your daughter here tell me
about her mom
uh so i mean mom she had her when she
was uh
in high school so teenage mom okay um my
wife was kind of hanging around the
the wrong crowd but when she got
pregnant at 16
it kind of changed uh the world you know
for her
and she wanted to be more than what she
was doing
you know she had a dream of being a
nurse
and just kind of turned it around from
there very cool
and what's the relationship like between
her mom
and your daughter it's pretty much the
same
uh because me and my wife are very
tight-knit you know it's kind of creepy
because we're uh we see either adam on a
lot of stuff where you know pretty much
type a personalities like
uh just you know if there's something to
get done let's get it done or or
you know just push ahead and my daughter
is
complete opposite hmm okay
so here's a i'm gonna paint you a full
picture and then give you a couple of
strategies here
and then um
then we can go from there and i want to
commit to stay in touch with you over
the next year or two all right
as you weather and navigate this okay
so when when somebody rattles off like
you just did
um teen mother father
left just never in the picture um
the cultural challenges of being a
biracial kid
raised by a third race by a biracial
couple right overseas on a military base
and then adding in um uh new siblings
one after the other after the other
that's a lot right and you know that
right
but when you put it all together in one
picture
the root question that that 17 year old
baby girl of yours
is continuing to ask and has been asking
since she was old enough to ask
questions
is why did my daddy leave me
and that question cannot be answered
with facts it can only be answered with
community
and connection and so
in steps you a man who has
committed his life to loving this girl
in a noble and extraordinary way
so good for you you have to know that
you are playing a long game here
okay and my guess is
the next couple of years are going to be
rocky and she needs to see boundaries
and she needs to know you cannot ignore
your parents in
our home you can't do that you don't
have permission to do that you're going
to be
a person of character you're going to
talk to us when we ask you questions
and also going to war with somebody who
is
still struggling isn't helpful either
and so
here's a couple of things that are just
coming to me on top of my head and you
may have some examples i'd love to hear
from you
but what i want to do is set up a
a regularly scheduled engagement with
you and her
and she's got to do this with her mom
quite honestly that's the relationship
that needs healing
um deep down she knows what a stud you
are
okay your daughter knows she's smart
enough to know that you're a good man
that came in and provided her and her
mom a place to live
and a stable home and no matter what she
says right now she's being 17 she's
testing boundaries she's
all over the place and so on and so
forth but she knows you're good
the person she needs to deeply deeply
connect with his mom
and to your knowledge have mom and her
ever gone out
and had the conversation about here's
who i was when i was 15 and 16.
here's some decisions i made his mom
ever sat down to talk to her about her
past
and the heartache and how challenging it
was
yes she's sat down with her a couple of
times
throughout the years whenever she wants
to find out more either
just kind of about her her dad her
biological dad okay
um and they've talked it's just it's
kind of tough
obviously especially for for her because
i know it's hard for her
yes they have had those conversations
okay so i want to make those types of
conversations
and more types of conversation i want to
make
that sort of communication a regular
practice in your home
and that might be once a week you've got
to go have
lunch or breakfast or dinner or whatever
with just one of us
and you and your wife can alternate and
you can tell your daughter
no electronics and you can sit there in
silence and just stare at me
but i'm gonna come up with a list of
questions to check in on you and see how
you're doing
and this might mean you are asking her
what her three favorite groups
music groups are and you're gonna have
to do you're gonna have to like get a
mma mouthpiece and bite down on it and
listen to those groups
and tell them that you think they're
like [ __ ] these are awful
or i don't understand this song help me
with this and when i'm at what i'm
asking you to do
is to lean into her world a little bit
and what that is going to do is show her
one key trait that she does not get
she's never been able to get because
this meant weakness and this meant
somebody else is gonna hurt her
and you're gonna teach her vulnerability
and you're gonna teach her not
vulnerability doesn't mean you can run
all over me and vulnerability doesn't
mean you don't have accountability
and vulnerability doesn't mean that you
can just do whatever you want because
you're 17 and i don't want to make you
mad
and it doesn't mean that your 17 year
old is suddenly gonna be like oh you
know what i'm just gonna
that's not gonna happen either but
you're teaching her a skill you're
teaching her a trait
that is relationship looks like somebody
doing something uncomfortable
even as little as i'll listen to your
music but oh man
or we're gonna read a book together or
we're gonna go
we're i'm gonna watch whatever weird
movie you want me to watch but you get
we're gonna go to breakfast and we're
gonna talk about it
so these breakfasts are non-negotiable
right
you live in my house this is gonna be
part of those and she's 17 so she may be
out in a year
so you don't have a ton of time that's
why i say usually i would say once a
month but you're running out of time and
so i would say every week
and offline i would ask you and your
wife to commit
to listening more at these
lunches at these breakfasts and talking
less giving less advice
and leaning in more get to know
your daughter and i know that you
already know i know they've had some
hard conversations before but i want you
to
invest in letting her voice be heard
because here's what she's going to do
she's going to practice letting her
voice be heard
and right now it feels like emotion it
feels like jumbled up mess inside that
17 year old head
and she's dealing with all of this stuff
starting with my dad didn't even care
enough about me to stick around
he didn't care enough to meet me
and i'm not african-american enough over
here i'm
not white enough over here well no i
don't don't even speak the language
because i'm overseas
or i'm just hanging a bunch of military
brat kids and now i'm back and i've got
three
kids in the house what in the world i
can't wait to just get out of here
right most of the time when a 17 year
old says i just want to get
just get out of here that's no they
don't mean that
what they're saying is i just want to
belong
i want to matter i want to have a role
in this home
and right now all this pain all of this
confusion is too much for my 17 year old
mind
i just want to run i just want to run i
just want to get out of here
and that's where you showing
vulnerability
leaning into that baby girl saying this
is what it looks like it looks like
paying for a meal
everybody drops their shoulders there's
no mad there's no frustrated there's
all right what's your three favorite
groups we're getting into this
tell me some things about you that i
don't know what's the funniest thing
that happened hey i thought of three
hilarious things that happened when i
was a kid that i've never even shared
with you
that looks like your wife being really
really vulnerable
and telling her what her relationship
with her mom and dad were like
and how she's trying so hard to be a
different kind of mom and what we're
looking for is connection points
out of vulnerability
that's a lot and here's the thing i said
earlier and i kind of blew over it you
are playing a long game now
17 18 if she packs up and moves out at
18
and she runs she says i'm out of here
she'll be back continue to love her
continue to write letters to her so she
can hold those letters and read them and
see them and feel them
and she'll keep them
continue to hold your boundaries firm
but continue to let that girl know that
she's loved
ah renee i want you to have that initial
conversation and i want you to have that
first
breakfast that first lunch and then i
want you to call me back because i want
to know how it went
and it may dude it may be a disaster it
may
be awful but it may be a tiny baby step
in the right direction